التحليل العسكري اذا والقراءه
الاستراتيجيه ينضم الينا من اسطنبول
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه العقيده
الركن حاتم ال كريم الفلاحي عقيد الفلاحي
اهلا بك اذا التطورات متسارعه المعارك
ضاريه على الارض والدعم الامريكي مستمر ما
هو النقص او الثغره
العسكريه التي ست تغطيها هذه الصفقه
الامريكيه الجديده او هذه الذخائر التي
اقر ايه الوزير وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انتوني بلينكن بيعها لاسرائيل الان ضمن
حاله طوارئ او ما سماها
كذلك نعم تحيه لكم من مشاهدي قناه الجزيره
لا شك بان هذه الصفقه هي ليست الاخيره في
مساله الدعم الامريكي للجيش الصهيوني الذي
يقاتل في غزه فلو تكلمنا عن الجسر الجوي
الذي وصل الى اكثر من 233 طائره في الفتره
الماضيه والى 30 سفينه شحن بالاضافه الى
ذلك بانه كانت في الفتره الماضيه تقديم
طلبات للحصول على
45 الف قنبله او قذيفه دبابات ميركافا
يضاف الى ذلك الان نتكلم
عن عن قذائف مدفعيه 155 ملم يضاف الى ذلك
بان المخازن الامريكيه المتواجده على
الاراضي المحتله في داخل الكيان الصهيوني
فتحت جميع هذه المخازن بعد السابع من
اكتوبر يضاف الى هذا كله بان هناك قنابل
تسمى بالقنابل الام 117 وهذه هي قنابل
غبيه تم استخدامها بشكل كبير جدا من قبل
الكيان الصهيوني في هذه الحرب وهذا هو
الذي سبب هذا الخراب والدمار كما راينا في
حي الرضوان قبل قليل بحيث تشير السي ان ان
الى انه نسبه الدمار من 40% الى 45% هي
نتيجه استخدام هذه القنابل الغبيه التي تم
تزويدها من قبل الولايه الات المتحده
الامريكيه الى الكيان الصهيوني وبالتالي
نحن نتكلم عن دعم مفتوح من قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ناهيك عن القوات التي
تقاتل مع القوات الصهيونيه قوات دلتا فورز
2000 2000 جندي يضاف الى ذلك المستشارين
والعسكريين يضاف الى ذلك 10 الا طن من
الاسلحه التي وصلت منذ بدايه العمليه
العسكريه الى يومنا هذا كل هذا الدعم
الامريكي والجيش الصهيوني كما نراه الان
هو في مازق حقيقي على على في ميادين قتال
نتيجه عدم تكييف هذه وتوظيف هذه الاسلحه
بالشكل الصحيح الذي الذي كان يجب عليه
باعتباره من الجيوش المتقدمه في المنطقه
ان يكون اداؤه اكبر من هذا بكثير ولكنه
نراه يلجا الى تدمير المنازل والبنه
التحتيه وقتل المدنيين وقتل الصحفيين وما
الى ذلك اذا ترى كل ما يجري من اخفاقات
للجيش الاسرائيلي هو نتيجه لعدم توظيف هذه
الاسلحه بالشكل الصحيح كما تقول عقيده
الفلاحي ماذا عن الخطه العسكريه التي يعمل
وفقها هذا الجيش كيف تراها هل تبدو لك
محكمه ام انها تعاني من ارتباك او ما يمكن
ان نسميه ارتباكا او
تخبطا نعم لا شك بان هذا الفشل العسكري هو
ليس في قضيه عدم التوظيف فقط وانما تتراكم
عليه عوامل متعدده من ضمن هذه هو سوء
التخطيط بالنسبه للقيادات العسكريه او سوء
التخطيط بالنسبه للقيادات السياسيه عندما
وضعت اهداف هي خارج امكانيه الجيش على
تحقيقها يضاف الى ذلك الفشل الاستخباري
يضاف الى ذلك بانه هناك اشكاليه في قله
الخبره لدى القاده الميدانيين و ولدى
القيادات المتدنيه بالنسبه لهذا الجيش في
القتال في المناطق المبنيه يضاف الى ذلك
تدني الروح المعنويه وعدم قدره الجندي على
القتال في مثل هذه المناطق هذه النقاط
بجميعها هي ادت الى تدني المستوى القتالي
بالنسبه للجيش الصهيوني يضاف الى الى ذلك
بانه المقاومه استطاعت في هذه المعركه ان
توظف الكثير من النقاط التي اصبحت عبا على
المهاجم في هذه القضيه ومنها بان الارض
اصبحت توظف بشكل كبير جدا من قبل القطعات
المدافعه خصوصا مع وجود الانفاق التي
استطاعوا ان يستخدمونها بشكل كبير خلال
هذه المعركه الامر الذي ادى الى حصول
خسائر يضاف الى ذلك الروح المعنويه
العاليه للمقاتلين والتدريب والقدره
البدنيه العاليه ادت الى حصول مثل هذه
الخسائر
يضاف الى هذا بانه حسن التدبير والخطه
المحكمه التي وضعها المدافع ايضا جعل جيش
الاحتلال يعاني من مازق حقيقي على جميع
الجبهات سواء كان في الشمال او في الوسط
او في الجنوب لذلك نرى بان العمليه
العسكريه تتعثر بشكل كبير جدا وهو غير
قادر لحد هذه اللحظه على تحقيق اي من
الاهداف نعم هناك انجازات تكتيكيه ولكن
هذه الانجازات التكتيكيه لم ترتقى ال لم
ترتقي الى المستوى العملياتي ولا الى
المستوى الستراتيجي لحد هذه اللحظه العقيد
الركن حاتم كريم الفلاحي الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا لك